good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Minard I will be filling in for
researcher Miller today the SCP were
going to be learning about is SCP 701
object class Euclid special containment
procedures all materials relating to SCP
701 are to be kept in a triple locked
archive at storage site these items
currently consists of the two currently
extant copies of the 16:40 cuarto 27
copies of the 1965 trade paperback
edition 10 copies of the 1971 hardcover
printing 21 floppy diskettes consisting
of data seized from raids on 1s VHS a
video cassette tape designated SCP 701
19 - a and 1 steal knife of unknown
origin designated SCP 701 19 be at no
time are any of these items to be
removed from the room access to the area
is to be heavily monitored absolutely no
personnel whatsoever is to be granted
access to the archive without the
express in person permission of doctors
description SCP 701 the Hanged king's
tragedy is a Caroline era revenge
tragedy in five acts performances of the
play are associated with southern
psychotic and suicidal behavior among
both observers and participants as well
as the manifestation of a mysterious
figure classified as SCP 701 - one
historical estimates placed the number
of lives claimed by the play at between
and over the past 300 years performances
of the Hanged king's tragedy did not
always end with an outbreak of this few
recorded performances only have ended in
SCP 701 events according to historical
records and investigations these
outbreaks generally follow the same
pattern one to two weeks prior to event
during the dress rehearsal period cast
members will weaken to spontaneously
deviate from the published text of the
play rather than improvisation or gaffes
associated with going off script set
deviations will be both orderly and
consistent as if the actors were working
off a new version of the script the
gasta production crew will seem unaware
of any change and if it is brought to
their attention will state that the
plane has run that way from the
beginning two to three hours prior to
event the outbreak generally occurs
during opening night or else at the
production with the greatest planned
attendance generally falling within the
first week after the plays opening one
to two hours before event SCP 701 - one
appears to be onstage in the final scene
of act 1 generally in the background or
to the side of the main action it may
seem to enter or exit the stage area but
does not appear to ever enter the
backstage or offstage area it simply
disappears when not on stage
the cast does not appear to notice or
comment on a CP 701 - one at least at
first the event SCP 701 - 1 appears
fully on stage during the banquet scene
and act 5 here it will be incorporated
into the action of the play as the
hanged Kane the cast will either murder
each other or commit suicide sometimes
using items that seem to appear
spontaneously on the stage rioting
breaks out in the audience with viewers
randomly attacking anyone in front of
them regardless of prior relationship
following the event if any of the
audience members survived the initial
outbreak they may exit the performance
space in which case they will continue
to engage in random or opportunistic
violence victims will generally require
sedation or restraint in this scenario
normal personality will begin to return
roughly 24 hours after the event
surviving victims will generally exhibit
signs consistent with a traumatic
experience some will have no
recollection of the event others may be
rendered permanently comatose or
psychotic for a typical case study of an
outbreak see incident report SCP 701 -
19 - 1 an analysis of the events leading
up to the last uncontained SCP 701 event
in 19 doing a high-school drama
performance in so now I'm going to go
through this so this is incident report
SCP 701 19-1 SCP involved is obviously
scp-705
location report prepared by doctor and
doctor on the content of scp-705 no.19
2a is a 187 millimeter by a 103
millimeter by 25 millimeter s VHS video
cassette tape recovered by investigators
from the scene of the incident a
performance of scp-705 tape was found in
a destroyed consumer grade camcorder
which was apparently recording the
performance from a vantage point within
the audience it is the only surviving
record of the event please see the SCP
701 archives for the full transcript of
the recording in order to compare the
identified deviations during a CP 701
event with the actual plot of the
published text C document SCP 701 1640
b1 tape begins 3 minutes 10 seconds
house lights go down 5 minutes 12
seconds curtain rises the play begins as
published with Gonzalo's coronation
speech 10 minutes 21 seconds a possible
sighting of SCP 701 - one during
Isabella's ravings an anomalous shadow
not belonging to one of the cast members
shows up along the back wall of the set
10 minutes 24 seconds shadow disappears
23 minutes 15 seconds first deviation
from the text rather than the dialogue
between Francisco and the courtesan the
curtain drops and comes back up on the
bare stage Antonio enters from the right
23 minutes 24 seconds first indirect
sighting of SCP 701 - 1 the shadow of a
figure seems to appear on the back wall
from stage right Antonio stops in place
and act surprised the shadow disappears
Antonio begins a long silly look we
confirming that he now believes this
Abella story doctor of notes that while
this soliloquy is in the style of the
rest of the play and seems to be
accurate Caroline era dialogue Antonio
speech in the scene does not exist in
the original text 24 minutes 12 seconds
curtain drops 24 minutes 51 seconds
curtain rises on Francisco and the
courtesan Antonio returns the play
continues as scripted 31 minutes 14
seconds first direct sighting of SCP 701
- one it enters and stands at the edge
of the stage left towards the end of act
2 scene 1 32 minutes 17 seconds
Gonzalo's dialog concludes as scripted
with the mention of an appointment with
the Ambassador from allagadda the exit
stage left
SCP 701 - one seems to turn and follow
him as the lights go down 38 minutes 13
seconds second sighting of SCP 701 - one
during act 3 scene 1 it appears on the
edge of stage right as Gonzalo and
Petruchio murder Sortino the scene
concludes with Gonzalo ordering his
cooks to prepare the corpse as a stew
script recovered from the scene indicate
that this section had been cut in
rehearsal 51 minutes 11 seconds third
sighting of SCP 701 - one appears close
this stage left as Antonio kills Isabela
one hour nine minutes 12 seconds fourth
sighting SCP 701 - one enters with
Gonzalo at the beginning of act 4 scene
1 and follows him throughout the scene
the scene also contains two key moments
first Gonzales seems to nod to SCP 701 -
1 when he mentions the ambassador of
allagadda
this is the first time a cast member has
seemed to indicate SCP 701 - ones
presence second the scene ends with a
deviation from the text whereas the
scripted speech at the end of act 4
scene one ends with Gonzalo considering
his own moral inequity Gonzalo here
seems to be more concerned that his
tribute will be sufficient for the
ambassador the lights go down one hour
twenty one minutes 15 seconds fifth
sighting SCP 701 - one enters stage left
at the end of Act four scene two as
Antonio leaves to secure a blade for his
coup rather than exiting Antonio stops
in front of SCP 701 - one who hands him
a long dagger this is believed to be the
first appearance of the item classified
as SCP 701 1915 note there is no mention
of the item in the prop list or the
other records maintained by the
production SCP 701 - 1 and Antonio
depart the stage together one hour 32
minutes 41 seconds sick deciding SCP 701
- one appears on stage left as Korn re
and Lauda Vico exit one hour 35 minutes
10 seconds lights come up act 5 scene 1
the banquet scene begins as scripted one
hour 40 minutes 52 seconds
Antonio enters bearing a piece of
parchment here the textual deviations
begin in earnest rather than the
parchment being petruchio's confession
as scripted Antonio instead describes it
as an invoice from the ambassador of
allagadda
proving that Gonzalo owes more tribute
than the intents to pay one hour 41
minutes 42 seconds
SCP 701 - one enters at this point from
stage right the entire cast seems to
perceive it
Gonzalo stands up curses as an aside to
the audience
runs for stage left the rest of the cast
including Olinda and Francisco who enter
from stage left physically restrained
Gonzalo and drag him back onto the stage
SCP 701 - 1 meanwhile moves to the
center of the stage where it stands in
front of Gonzales thrown one hour 43
minutes 8 seconds a noose is dropped
onto the stage from above the cast
forced Gonzalo into the noose as he
begins to curse in Italian and in one
place possibly Latin the noose is drawn
taut in the cast drops Gonzalo he begins
to asphyxiate 1 hour 43 minutes 32
seconds Antonio speaks with this the
tribute in full it is paid the actor
takes SCP 701 19-2 the dagger and draws
it across Gonzalo stomach spilling his
intestines across the stage one hour 44
minutes 4 seconds Linda takes the dagger
from Antonio she speaks with this fools
blood
it is the Hanged kings she cuts
Antonio's throat one hour 45 minutes 31
seconds ropes drop from the roof of the
stage a noose for each cast member the
cast assembles underneath them a Linda
takes position next to SCP 701 - one one
hour 46 minutes 12 seconds Linda says
with this our blood it is the Hank
Keynes the cast hang themselves
one hour 47 minutes 33 seconds SCP 701 -
one moves through the hanging corpses
and - front center stage one hour 47
minutes 41 seconds the stage lights cut
out one hour 47 minutes 46 seconds
sounds of screaming and physical
violence around the camera one hour 48
minutes 22 seconds a loud sound most
likely the camera being knocked over one
hour 49 minutes one second the camera is
destroyed the tape ends for more
information on the plays published text
C document SCP 701 1640 b1 in short SCP
701 is a self-evolving mimetic virus
transmitted through unknown means
through the text of the play dr.
theorize the SCP 701 events may involve
this hypothesis is consistent with a
spike in levels detected via satellite
in the vicinity of the 19th incident
indicating foundation agents are under
standing orders to suppress any
performance or publication of ICP 701
whenever found or detected despite our
best efforts to the contrary however the
plane remains freely available online
sometimes under different titles all
attempts to detect or isolate the origin
of these copies have failed suppression
of the place publication has generally
been successful with most copies of a
1971 scholarly edition destroyed before
distribution
nonetheless copies of the 1965 trade
paperback turn up with some regularity
in both colleges and high school
libraries agents are to obtain or
otherwise destroy these items whenever
possible
history the first known publication of
the Hanged kings tragedy was a cuarto
dated 1640 the plays author is not
listed the publisher 1 William cook
disappeared from the historical record
soon thereafter strangely the text does
not appear in the stationers register
the first known as CP 701 event on
record occurred in 18th during a
performance of the play it USA other
significant incidents include the 19th
performance at a small theatre the 1964
performance at the University the 19th
performance at university the first SCP
701 event successfully suppressed by the
foundation the 19th performance by a
student group in CA the 90 television
adaptation by the Broadcasting
Corporation the production of this was
successfully shut down by the foundation
before the broadcast and the 19th
incident its
OAH us a designated SCP 701 19th 4-1
publication history original 1640 quarto
all known copies in foundation custody
17:33 folio edition republished 1790
1813 cambridge university press edition
1965 trade paperback edition 1971
hardcover edition agent should note that
copies of the play have often been
misfiled under different titles or
spellings of the title
furthermore photocopies of the 1965 text
have been found in circulation
throughout college theatre departments
in the continental United States and the
United Kingdom
additional given the highly probability
of in my mind I again recommend that SCP
701 be upgraded to cater class the SCP
701 mimetic virus may very well be the
forefront of an invasion scenario
furthermore dr. P and for some reason
one two three seven one one six zero six
zero is written after the name curious
and in response to this denied none of
the current information we have on a CP
701 indicates a XK class scenario until
we have additional data classification
will remain at euclid face facts doctor
the cat's been long out of the bag on
this one and in this line of business we
consider ourselves lucky if we only lose
a hundred people or so every ten years
all five and written next to his name is
one two three seven one nine seven zero
six zero okay thank you very much for
listening everyone
you have homework please read document
SCP 701 1640 b1 thank you for listening
you are dismissed thank you
you